It's time to launch the rest of your
cluster from the Ambari node image.
Launch six instances,
these should also m3.large instances and
given 30 gigabytes of storage each.
Call it something like Ambari node, and
otherwise, set all
the options like before.
Once the instances are launched, you'll
want to configure the security rules.
You'll need the internal host names,
the private DNS of each of your
instances, so copy these into a file.
Mine looks like this.
Those names also show the IP addresses
of each instance, these numbers here.
This one is 172.31.15.28.
You need allow for communication between
the nodes by opening all the ports on
the subnet containing the instances.
Look at the IP addresses.
Note the network number, the first
set of numbers in the IP address.
Here it's 172, but for
you it might be different.
Check out the security group for
the nodes, then edit the inbound rules.
Create a new custom TCP rule.
Set the Port to a range from 0 to 65535.
And the Source to x.0.0.0/8,
where x is your network number.
In my case it's 172, but again,
for you it's probably different.
This allows the nodes to connect to
other hosts on the subnet with IP
addresses starting with x.172.
Be sure this rule is added to
the Ambari server as well.
If you don't know about subnets and
want to learn more,
check out our networking course.
I'll give you the link.